les amis c'est la saint valentin avec un
peter d'amoureux
[Applaudissements]
et là bas aussi n'a pas si c'est ça
passait pas
[Applaudissements]
montre en main
à ces choux
ouais
du coup en mode du lundi matin dont il
faut hélas non toujours impeccable et un
regard d'enfant williams de ce côté là
on a froid on a de la marinière la mode
la mode la mode mais y'a que ça de vrai
moi mon pti
le voici le voilà venez manger chez lui
chez jack up make up make up chp à quoi
c'est bon j'ai dit ah non sans nous
soucier doit alors tu peux parler dit à
gmail.com
on peut manger ou c'est comme les
accords au brouillard toi tu prépares ta
playlist
ben oui c'est ça qui allait faire
regarder les ans en eau et comment on
peut l'obtenir cette barre on adore
reversus blondel c'est vous qui
choisissez
et de là elle habite chez pull merci
beaucoup c'est tranquille
il est sur un bateau leur hymne à la
volée avec ce jour là tu dis allons
donner notre argent des prix cassés
[Musique]
à
on est parti sur un rang plus tard
mon nom
[Musique]
on sent le travail
ouais malgré leur usine au brésil aurait
voulu que je me bats ta mère ton nom
allez un doublé 1 d'apple bon démission
moins d'un ben haim un bon la maison
monsieur merci merci on a fait des
émissions qui m'a dit c'est la coupe
sécurité bah je sais pas tout les
rafraîchir un peu c'est quoi cette
conversation grand-mère à les battants
des mois des courriels
bonjour qu'est ce qui se passe
un tournage à une magnifique acté ce
faux bond qui vont aller au petit palais
[Musique]
pas pour toi la cena vous êtes très bien
la tv en plateau c'est hyper bien en
revanche sur les prises de parole
bonsoir bonsoir
asuivre bonsoir 55 ans c'est samedi soir
bonsoir
avec isabelle ithurburu laden voilà
voilà
[Musique]
alain penin
là